hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ich darf euch heute hier endlich
willkommen heißen zum zweiten Teil von
Baby in yellow und mit zweitem Teil
meine ich Nacht Nummer zwei denn wir
müssen heute in der zweiten Nacht
babysitten und auf das Baby aufpassen
dass sich
wo befindet
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
du bist drei dicker warum guckst du
Fernsehen niemals schlafen dicker
[Musik]
hinter der Vase oh Flasche aus dem
Kühlschrank nehmen wir sollen also das
Baby füttern das ganze ist ein
horrorspielen ich werde
[Musik]
ich werde mich aber nicht auf diese
Horror Thematik einlassen und einfach
ganz entspannt Hintergrundmusik laufen
lassen
wir machen uns hier gar keinen Stress
[Musik]
die Flasche ist weg
es geht sehr gut los wir müssen jetzt
wahrscheinlich alles durchgucken
kochen für Windeln
warum kocht also für eine kranke Nummer
[Musik]
oh hi
oh
ganz entspannt tomato wir füttern das
Baby gönn dir bisschen
natürlich wieder das Baby mit und laufen
rüber zum Wickeltisch setzen ihn wieder
hier drauf zack neben uns die Windel
der Typ
ist vielleicht eins
und kann furzen
wie ein Elefant wir müssen jetzt
allerdings anscheinend hier erstmal die
Windel holen die weg
oh mein Gott Alter
ich kotz im Arsch ne
ach Bruder ey lass mich einfach in Ruhe
hey ich könnte doch wirklich
[Musik]
abgeschlossen
wie geht's
3 2 1
oh mein Gott ich habe jetzt nicht
gesehen was passiert ist aber die Windel
ist anscheinend im Schlafzimmer gelandet
und gegen die Wand gesprungen also gut
wir nehmen die Windel mit und werden das
Baby wickeln auf ganze entspannt wir
machen uns gar kein Stress alles easy
hallo Baby hier ist eine Winkel Windel
so wir müssen das Baby ins Bett bringen
oben links übrigens nur für euch zur
Info
[Musik]
oben links nur für euch zur Info
stehen immer die Aufgabe die wir machen
müssen und wir müssen jetzt gerade das
Baby ins Bett bringen ich könnte meine
Camps zwar auch einfach ein bisschen
weiter runter schieben bin allerdings
ein faules Stück Scheiße von daher
lassen wir die Cam darüber und ihr seht
einfach mich anstatt die Aufgaben habe
ich davor also Baby ins Bett bringen so
geh schlafen
ein Geschichtenbuch finden und Hinsetzen
so setzen und lesen den Baby wieder was
vor es geht als das
[Musik]
ich glaube der will wieder Englisch
sprachen lernen einfach er will
wahrscheinlich wieder die Plüschkatze
haben
nee dann immer den Hasen
richtig und jetzt wollen wir weiter
lesen wahrscheinlich ne genau setzen wir
uns wieder hin und lesen Sie weiter vor
aus Prinz und Kaninchen so weiter
Alter Ende und jetzt Schlafenszeit okay
das heißt wir gehen wahrscheinlich
wieder runter schließen wir die Tür
ich mache mir hier gar keinen Stress ich
[Musik]
doch überall
ich
de gerade
Mann wo kommt der denn her der hat eine
Plüsch Dings offen
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
du gehst ins Bett mein Gott was haben
wir denn hier überhaupt
steht Müller vor der Tür na gut okay es
ist kein Horrorspiel es ist kein
Horrorspiel wir haben ganz entspannte
Musik es ist einfach ein Babysitter
Spiel ganz easy hier passiert nichts
schlimmes wir nehmen die Kiste den Toast
die hood
ist das Plüschtier
[Musik]
wo ist das Plüschtier
ich denke mal der Toast die Huss die
acht Toast die 4000 ich denke mal der
muss in die Küche ne
jetzt da auf Wohnzimmertisch stellen
also gut nehme für 1000 und stellen auf
dem Wohnzimmertisch
Fernseh gucken
jetzt passiert hoffentlich nichts mehr
und wir schlafen ein
alles entspannt
[Musik]
wir haben Nacht Nummer zwei geschafft
das Problem ist
es wartet noch eine dritte Nacht
[Musik]
und ja
Freunde
das ist jetzt halt die Frage
soll man nach drei auch noch spielen
sondern die ganze Baby in yellow
Babysitter Geschichte zu Ende bringen
oder
[Musik]
soll man sagen in diesem zweiten Teil in
der zweiten Nacht sind jetzt schon so
viele Sachen passiert dass wir einfach
sagen Kat ich habe nichts dagegen ich
hasse Horrorspiele ihr kennt mich ich
bin extrem schreckhaft bei sowas immer
ich bin in einer gar keinen Fan von aber
entscheidet als mal unten in die
Kommentare ciao